titles were so important i learned that
titles have to translate globally you
know we can come up with the greatest
title in the world if that doesn't
translate into 14 different languages
it's not a good title
we understand your strategy is to
develop a log line and a synopsis
and will you try to pitch investors
first or the distributors
you're asking me personally
um
i
often will come up for me a title is
important i i get stuck in a mud without
a cool title
my movies may suck but our titles are
cool
and i need that that gives me some fuel
we know the stories we want to tell
and synopsises
we come up with a with an idea what
what's what's our idea what's the story
and that inspires it and we just start
you know who who are the players who are
the protagonists antagonists who are the
you know what's the hero's journey what
are their what are their pitfalls and
hurdles gonna be
you know what's what's the ticking time
bomb what's gnawing at them
and then we we go through it and you
know break it down and start doing our
development notes and
and
when i get excited about it i call our
investors and i say you know
we're ready you know we're ready to go
and we know the story we want to tell
and usually it's just a paragraph that
they want
from us um
you know that that's at least in our
situation that's what we do we we get to
do what we want to do we're very
fortunate
so we there's it's it's pretty much
coming up with the story we want to tell
and going and doing it and and let ships
fall where they may
you know it kind of comes back to
doing things the way you want to do them
and
not
not allowing people to tell you how to
do things or why do you think we're open
to you know suggestions and stuff but we
tell the stories we want to tell and we
cast the people we want to cast and we
make the movies we want to make
and we don't ask for permission
so if the title is very important to you
how much back and forth and
disagreements have you had over titles
and has that
put the kibosh on
the beginning
sorry to cut you off titles have never
been a problem that's that's one thing
that i often come up with um the film
that we're starting in september
we
we we had about a five second clash on a
title there were two titles that we both
liked
and
[Music]
we're going with the other one and the
more i think about it the more cool i am
with it but
um titles it's never been a problem i
just when i was writing i needed a title
i needed a title to get excited if i
didn't have i couldn't be i couldn't get
excited about it
i needed to get excited about
blowing smoke i need to get excited
about you know
double threat i need to get excited
about break even i needed
once i had a title i can just that's all
i need and i can just i'm all in
give me that title and i'm all in you
know at least in my world it's so
important to me
you know it's everything it's everything
and it doesn't mean my titles are great
but
at least to me they are right i mean we
all love our children
so the untitled shane stanley project is
not going to work for you no you can't
no
get out of bed at 2 a.m to start typing
for that no
no
does not
there are there are no untitled shane
stanley scripts or projects i promise
you it has to have a title if it's going
to get the time of day for me
yeah
it's really important and you seem to
like shorter titles or no i think
they're easier for people to remember
i you know i mean
i i'm not saying all the titles that
i've had are are winners at the end of
the day but i i learned early you know i
i did a couple of films with avi lerner
back in the day and
because he sold globally titles were so
important i learned that titles have to
translate globally you know we can come
up with the greatest title in the world
if that doesn't translate into 14
different languages it's not a good
title
and that's really important and you know
something that people can remember
something that people say often you know
people say i break even you know they're
a double threat
you know oh he's just blowing smoke you
know those are the kind of titles that
that appeal to me
a lot
you know that's just me personally but i
remember that i remember when when i was
working with avi when blockbuster and
hollywood video were still a thing
he used to say
when you come up with a title
it's important to remember people are
going to start at new releases at a and
they're going to work their way to z
most people are done choosing by the
time we get to m
which is funny our most successful film
was with an n no code of conduct with
avi but
that was just kind of his model in
coming up with titles
so i never forgot that
and people laugh at me when i throw that
out because they're like blockbuster or
what and it's different now because
everything's on a thumbnail everybody's
you know checking stuff online or gets
promoted and doesn't matter but that was
obvi's mentality and you think about the
success avi lerner has had over the last
30 or 40 years as being one of the most
prolific independent filmmakers in
history
okay that's some advice i learned from
avi
that's one thing i'll take away from
that relationship
yeah so titles are important something
catchy quick simple
you know what is the three billboards
outside of ebbing's montana i mean but
that worked it worked but what did
everybody call it
i don't know three billboards okay yeah
do you see throw both three that's a
tongue twister right
had you seen billboards yet that's what
i remember
yeah do you always go to a distributor
first with your idea um i i run it by
them
i'll run it by them you know i have a
good relationship with with a
distributor that um
that we have and i i just tell them this
is what we're doing i mean i i i don't
mean that
i just i i we go make the films we want
to make people can catch it or they they
don't have to
um
we're we're at a point
where
i don't care if it's it's going in the
dirt with 50 grand and a couple of
stolen cameras and we're going to shoot
our movie you know fortunately we
haven't had to do that yet but i would
that's what we were going to do with
double threat during covet we literally
had 50 grand offered to us to do
something during covet
and we were we were all in and we got
fortunate and
one of our backers was excited to hear
we wanted to do something
and said no let's let's do it right but
that's our mentality we just want to
make movies they'll find a home
they'll find a home
so
you know it takes time to get to that
point and it's it's it's just being able
to do the things you want with the
people you love
and the people that are behind you
whether they're writing to check or
putting the film out get what you do and
they know what they're going to they
know what to expect with us
they know what they're going to get
so
you know
it's i talked to a distributor the other
day and it was
oh you're making a movie when do you
start september 28th oh would you do you
want to tell us what this one is
oh i can't sure
you know
that was a discussion we're making it
anyway
hope you enjoy it
will you ever have a full screenplay
written when you pitch distributors or
only the idea i'm not going to talk to a
distributor until i'm financed
so i mean that's just me personally i
i'm not going to waste anybody's time
i'm not going to call an actor i'm not
going to call
anybody until we're you know at this
point where it's like okay yeah we can
make a movie
um
often who reads scripts anymore i mean
you can't get agents to read them lord
knows they don't do that you know or
distributors really going to read a
script no they want to see a dumb movie
they want to know what you're doing
you know they're just going to throw it
to somebody for coverage
and if you're making your movies based
on coverage i think that's a bad thing
some of the greatest movies in history
got covered so poorly some of the worst
moves in history were some of the
greatest coverage films i mean it's it's
you know it's who's reading and who's
covering
um sometimes coverage is done out of
respect while somebody will say well we
want to take this out
um we'd like to take a look at it and
get some coverage on it okay and they
usually call back so you checked all the
boxes it's it's fine go go have fun go
do it but that's it's not how we make
movies it's it's not about committee
it's it takes a team
but
we our job is to make the film and it's
not
our job to distribute or sell it and we
have a mutual respect where
you know what you're going to get when
we do something and i know what to
expect from you when you're going to put
it out and i won't tell you how do you
do your job let me do mine
and that's the relationships that we
like to have with our distributors and
sales agents and
it's just it's just you know it comes
from time time and time it's been beaten
a bag for you know producing films for
over 30 years you
you can
you know get to a situation with some
people that are willing to trust you and
it's about trust it's about doing films
and another reason i'm an indie rat is i
like i don't i don't put our investors
at risk you know make the movie for what
it can get made for
so the the the stakes are low so people
aren't you know you're not ending up
wearing cement shoes in two years
because you know couldn't give something
away that cost millions of dollars i
mean it happens all the time that's not
how we make our movies we make our
movies we punch way above our weight
class
we we weigh our kick our punk coverage
on these things we get great cast great
crew we make them look as good as we can
it's a roger corman idea it's the same
mentality i mean how many films did
roger corbin kick out
you know
it's it's just about doing what we love
and getting them done and and
having fun
and giving giving people content
that's our job and um i i don't like to
over complicate it i i will
i will never
go to a distributor without a script i
mean there's nothing to talk about if
there's no money you know i i don't talk
to them until it's it's where finance
we're ready to go and then
we're making it
that's just that's just the timeline of
what we do now